on va parler de football à présent mais
pas de n'importe quel football de
freestyle football la marque le
Bouteiller vous êtes originaire de
Voisins le bretonneux et vous avez
commencé à pratiquer cette discipline à
l'âge de 12 ans aujourd'hui vous avez 17
ans et vous êtes champion de France
junior et champion du monde de foot
freestyle alors vous nous avez un petit
peu expliqué comment est-ce que vous été
lancés dans cette discipline mais
pourquoi est-ce que ça vous a autant plu
alors ça m'a plu parce que c'était un
sport complètement individuel et donc ma
progression dépendait que de moi donc et
puis j'ai toujours été très fan de foot
ça s'en rapproché beaucoup j'ai toujours
aimé jongler quand je pratiquais le
football et quand j'ai vu des gens plus
expérimentés que moi j'ai tout de suite
voulu refaire pareil et au fil du temps
j'ai commencé à progresser un petit peu
et au fil du temps je voulais toujours
plus toujours plus et depuis ça s'est
jamais arrêté et du coup on peut dire
que maintenant jouer un niveau
professionnel alors si on veut oui
puisque mon sport est en plein
développement donc c'est
professionnel ou amateur la différence
est très petite donc je pratique je fais
beaucoup d'heures tous les jours donc je
pratique comme quelqu'un comme n'importe
quel sportif de haut niveau donc on peut
dire ça que je suis professionnel et
vous avez participé à deux grandes
compétitions du coup championnat de
France junior des moins de 16 ans et le
Championnat du Monde comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu ces expériences alors les
championnats de France en juniors ça a
été c'était une très belle expérience
j'ai eu une longue préparation pour être
préparée mentalement et et
psychologiquement et puis physiquement
j'avais prépare justement à ces
compétitions là comment on se prépare et
ben c'est un peu comme tout on répète on
répète on répète et voilà se prépare je
répète beaucoup mais gestes je prends
toutes les mesures possibles j'observe
mes adversaires pour voir
pour essayer d'être le moins surpris
possible et voilà on va dire que vous
avez un 7 prédéfini dans votre dans
votre mémoire et puis vous le faites
vous faites les figures les enchaîner et
alors est-ce qu'il y a une figure qui
est plus compliquée plus compliquée
qu'une autre alors il y a des figures
qui sont beaucoup plus compliquées que
d'autres après tout dépend quand on les
maîtrise ça devient facile mais
en particulier surtout avec le stress la
pression les enjeux qui peut y avoir et
le public qui regarde
il y a des figures qui deviennent deux
fois plus compliquées deux fois plus
compliqué qu'elle entraînement mais
sinon les figures les plus compliquées
c'est celle où il y a des roulades ou
des acrobaties comme le salto arrière ou
salto avant la figure de la plus
difficile à apprendre pour vous ça a été
oui c'est un milieu il y a beaucoup de
compétitions il y a beaucoup de
football freestyler alors en France il y
a pas tant que ça il faudrait un peu
plus de monde mais mais on est déjà
assez nombreux un petit peu et voilà il
y a beaucoup de compétitions il y en a
pas beaucoup en France mais à
l'international il y en a et il y a de
quoi faire et du coup dans ces
compétitions est-ce qu'il y a des règles
à suivre enfin il y a des notations
enfin comment ça se passe alors il y a
plusieurs formats de compétition mais le
plus classique c'est les battles donc ça
va être des battles donc principalement
on va avoir deux personnes donc un
contrat et ça va être trois passages de
30 secondes et voilà et il y a cinq
juges qui déterminent qui a gagné en
fonction de certains critères et
notamment le style et les erreurs et la
difficulté des gestes est-ce que vous
aimeriez
voir le le football freestyle aux Jeux
Olympiques un jour
c'est un grand grand rêve et justement
du coup on parlait un peu des
compétitions est-ce que vous avez
d'autres objectifs enfin vous souhaitez
atteindre d'autres objectifs
alors oui j'ai quelques objectifs
j'aimerais beaucoup être champion de
France
l'année dernière j'ai je suis arrivé
troisième donc maintenant j'aimerais
vraiment pouvoir
aller jusqu'au titre et après pourquoi
pas grappiller quelques places sur le
plan européen et sur le plan mondial
faire les meilleures performances
possible le niveau est élevé en France
en France le niveau est très élevé ça
augmente constamment et c'est pareil
pour l'international du coup il y a une
véritable communauté autour de cette
discipline alors il y a une grande
communauté en France entre freestyler on
se connaît à peu près tous ou presque et
à l'international il y a également une
grande communauté donc il y a des
freestyler un petit peu partout dans le
monde et
voilà il y a des événements auxquels on
peut se regrouper chaque année et c'est
une communauté qui est vraiment géniale
et c'est un monde vraiment génial
est-ce qu'on peut ça ressemble
finalement plus au skate ou au break
exactement
comme le break sauf que c'est avec un
ballon donc oui qui est différent aussi
je sais pas peut-être un peu plus sport
de rue ou oui oui c'est vraiment un
sport où on a besoin que d'un ballon
pour pratiquer donc où qu'on soit on
peut on peut le pratiquer il suffit d'un
ballon et on peut faire ça avec qui on
veut ou on veut et voilà alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire une petite
démonstration j'avoue que j'ai très
envie de voir comment est-ce que vous
vous débrouillez ben je vous laisse
aller tranquillement sur le petit
plateau qu'on a préparé pour vous juste
derrière on va vous mettre une petite
musique pour vous mettre dans l'ambiance
[Musique]
c'est presque artistique bah oui c'est à
la jonction entre le sport et
l'artistique justement
faut beaucoup d'équilibre aussi j'ai
l'impression
d'équilibre vous aviez déjà entendu
parler le
football Sandrine
merci beaucoup Marc le Bouteiller
accepter notre invitation et puis pour
cette superbe démonstration merci